-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here!
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. That applause lasted
longer than CNN+.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
If you haven't heard, today
it was announced that
the streaming service CNN+
is shutting down just 32 days
after it launched.
That's right, CNN+ is gone,
which means in six months,
it'll be turned into
Spirit Halloween+.
[ Laughter ]
32 days, oh, my --
I've had avocados
that last longer than that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was doing so badly,
all they had to do was call
their one subscriber like,
"Hey, Doug, we're not going to
do this."
[ Laughter ]
You could tell this was on
the horizon though when CNN
had a CNN countdown clock
to the end of CNN+.
It was very interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's get to some news
or what we think might be news.
Did you guys see this?
Piers Morgan interviewed
former president Trump,
and he released a promo that
shows Trump storming out
after refusing to admit
that he lost the election.
But now Trump is claiming
he never stormed out
and that Piers Morgan actually
doctored the footage.
[ Laughter ]
In Trump's defense,
I really don't see him
"storming" anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
If you haven't seen the clip,
here it is.
-The most explosive interview of
the year.
-I don't think you're real.
Very dis--
Let's finish up the interview.
-Morgan versus Trump.
-Turn the camera off.
Very dishonest.
[ Laughter ]
-My only question is has Trump
been living at Mar-A-Lago
or under a heat lamp
at Golden Corral?
[ Laughter ]
I was wondering.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I was wondering that.
He's done!
-Nice.
-Flip him over!
-Texas toast.
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of crazy things on TV,
last night was a new episode of
"The Masked Singer,"
and the Jack-in-the-box
was revealed to be
Rudy Giuliani.
Watch this.
-Oh, my goodness!
Former associate
attorney general --
-Oh, my God.
-Former mayor of New York City,
Rudy Giuliani!
-♪ I'm here to tell you, honey ♪
♪ That I'm bad to the bone ♪
♪ Bad to the bone ♪
♪ Bad, real bad, very bad ♪
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it actually takes
talent not to hit any notes.
I think that's actually --
[ Laughter ]
After seeing that, the CDC
reinstated the mask mandate.
They're like,
"Put the mask back on now.
Now we're putting the mask
back on."
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Just put it -- For all of us."
Well, this was nuts.
Last night, the Army --
the Army dropped parachutists
into the Washington Nationals'
baseball stadium, but the FAA
forgot to tell the Capitol
it was happening, so they
thought the plane was a threat
and evacuated the Capitol.
[ Audience laughs, gasps ]
Come on, you can't sneak up
on the Capitol like that!
That's like throwing
a surprise party for someone
who just had a heart attack.
It's like, "Hey!"
Can't do that!
[ Laughter ]
Thankfully, everything was fine
until Nancy Pelosi got back
and was like, "Damn it, who
the hell took my podium again?
Alright, come on now.
It's not funny."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, get this.
Apparently a source close to
Bernie Sanders said that he
might run for president in 2024
if Joe Biden doesn't.
So I guess the Democratic ticket
in 2024
is between the Muppets
in the balcony.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Statler 2024!"
Hey, here's some good news.
Today is Queen Elizabeth's
96th birthday.
Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy birthday.
And to celebrate,
the royal family posted
a brand-new photo of her.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
Wow, the new "Game of Thrones"
spinoff looks great.
I think it's --
[ Laughter ]
Who knows?
I'm telling you, she's got to
stop feeding the corgis.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Looks like she's starring in
a Budweiser commercial.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the Queen turned 96 today,
and we wanted to wish her
a happy birthday
the only way we know how.
So without further ado,
please welcome the wait staff
from the Times Square
Applebee's.
Come on out, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Applebee's is fun,
it's true ♪
-♪ Especially when we sing
for you ♪
-♪ Good news is
we sing for free ♪
-♪ Bad news is we sing off-key ♪
-♪ Sound off ♪
-♪ Happy ♪
-♪ Birthday ♪
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much, guys.
Good to see you, everybody.
Thank you for being here.
That was good. Not bad.
That's the real --
-Aw, such a thrill.
-Times Square Applebee's, go get
their autograph tonight, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, people are talking
about this.
In Florida, a bride and wedding
caterer have been arrested
for allegedly lacing the lasagna
at her wedding with cannabis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap for that.
[ Laughter ]
People were suspicious after
watching the bride and groom
feed each other
the entire wedding cake.
[ Laughter ]
That definitely explains why
the father/daughter dance
was to a four-hour
Grateful Dead bootleg.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I heard about a man
in North Carolina who robbed
a dollar store, regretted it,
and then returned all the cash.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, apparently the guy looked
around the store and said,
"You know, I think you guys need
this more than I do."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a 21-year-old
Chihuahua has officially claimed
the title of the world's
oldest dog.
The dog is so old,
he fetches the tennis ball,
and then puts it on the bottom
of his walker.
We have a great show, everybody.